Hollywood mr. and mrs. audience
Hollywood the magical mecha movie lair
Fountainhead of the celluloid fantasies
whose shining shadows flicker around the
full circumference of our troubled world
Hollywood where science and sorcery
combine to brew their magic broth of
thrills and chills of laughter and tears
for audiences like you totally 250
million people a week where it is to you
mr. and mrs. audience that all Hollywood
is dedicated for you little Tommy ticket
buyer do some 70,000 Hollywood workers
exert their labors their brains their
witchcraft but I wonder little Mary
matinee if you know who is most sought
after in all the busy bedlam of
Hollywood of course highly advantageous
to know is the cameraman and eagerly
besieged for favor as the director
hungrily desired as any association with
the glamorous stars most respectfully
regarded as the writer but not even one
of these is Hollywood's most coveted
personality
there is another whose Fame and
importance transcend all else in
Hollywood ooh I I am the most
frantically sort person in cinema land I
Oscar the Academy Award true I'm only a
metal statuette intrinsically worth but
a few dollars but money cannot buy me I
must be earned
the reward for outstanding merit they
tell me I'm only 13 years old but that's
a falsehood I was born perhaps 10
million years ago when primitive man
first began his epic March to nowadays
Brian progress I am achievement I am
that recognition of achievement for
which mankind will always strive so long
as he is a very human mankind
and I am also you mr. and mrs. audience
you who demand and receive each year
finer and finer entertainment on the
silver screen my present incarnation
began in the year 1927 when the creative
minds of Hollywood fulfilling a long
felt desire conceived through the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences a plan to honor through me the
progress of their fellow workers the
birth of the now world-famous Academy
Awards
mommy for whistling while he worked his
myriad wonders with Snow White
Hollywood's marvelous master of whimsy
Walt Disney receives not only me but
seven little Oscar it's the 1938 Irving
Thalberg award was presented to Hal
Wallis significant of his consistent
production achievements but who's this
can it be yes George Bernard Shaw the
whiskered Lion of literature calls me
with his dulcet words to cross the
Atlantic and tell him we voted Pygmalion
a great screen story 1939 and now we
prepare our vote for the past year
already more than 12,000 votes have been
received votes by artists and artisans
stars and technicians alike from all the
manifold activities of Hollywood votes
counted and recorded in the strictest
privacy by public accountants and
Hollywood talks of little else as the
evening approaches the Academy dinner
come with me mr. and mrs. audience and
you Tommy and Mary too to the Coconut
Grove in the Ambassador Hotel see for
yourself
and be conscious as I am of the
outstanding mood of this brilliant
gathering suspense who will win the
Academy Awards the tension grows and
grows that allows his thought of little
else disgust for not one whisper of
Hollywood's choices has been allowed to
escape everybody's here everybody's
curious covetous envious perhaps but
excited for dearly cherished as the
recognition by our fellow workers of our
efforts remember I am Oscar the ultimate
glory in Hollywood success yes
everybody's here tall bashful James
Stewart and the lovely girl the quite
fabulous mr. Charles Lawton with his
distinguished wife Elsa Lanchester
Revere Jean Hersholt and his missus torn
tonight for his fireside and first
editions did you ask for glamor mr. and
mrs. audience well Hedy Lamarr's here
but darn it with her husband Jean
Marquis Melvyn Douglas Helen Gahagan
Irving Pitts show everybody you bet
everybody Scarlett O'Hara her glorious
self Vivien Leigh escorted by producer
David Selznick of course I don't have to
tell you that this is dear old Mei
Robson
one of the youngest of them all or that
this is one of the loveliest Olivia de
Havilland escorted by John Hay Whitney
naturally the press is well and
brilliantly represented famed the Wella
Parsons and her husband dr. Harry Martin
Hedda Hopper actress columnist beaming
in her own gracious person in with her
John Carroll comes Jack Warner youngest
of the Warner clan and then the senior
member of the film famed brothers Harry
Warner look Andy Hardy sweetheart a and
Rutherford a nut with Andy scandal
blonde lovely Virginian Bruce and her
husband producer Jay Walter Rubin
distinguished scientist English father
Douglas Fairbanks Jr but here's Elsa max
will start the party folks now
everything's ready to go but who's going
to win Vivien Leigh and Laurence Olivier
wonder with me so do Mickey Rooney and
MGM ZJ medics gorgeous heady eyes that
table crowded with my gleaming offspring
and with Judy Garland Norma Shearer and
George Raft anxiously awaits the
Academy's momentous decisions
everybody is here tonight stars and
starlets executives and electricians
workers and writers technicians and
telephone girls engineers and extras
directors and designers everybody and
movie land
watching waiting wondering who will win
me Oscar for 1939 meanwhile in another
part of the Ambassador Hotel I Oscar
Hamlet in honesty in a guarded press
room newspaper representatives from the
whole world await as to the new
president water Ranger [ __ ] envelopes
containing the names of this year's
winners sealed envelopes to be opened
only at a certain moment so that the
folks back east may read the names of
the proud new Oscar owners in their
morning papers but now back to the
Coconut Grove and hurry for the retiring
president Frank Capra is turning the
gathering over to the incoming president
producer Walter Ranger and now let's get
right to it
the awards of 1939 first the technical
awards which will be presented by the
chairman of the Research Council and
winner of last year's Thalberg award mr.
Darryl zanuck mr. zanuck deals out My
glittering replicas in quick succession
to William Cameron Menzies for his
outstanding use of color in Gone with
the Wind to dr. Herbert T Kalmus pres
and of technicolor a special Oscar for
color development - Hal Kern and James
Newcomb for film editing gone with the
wind
- Ernest Tyler color cinematography and
the same - ray Ranahan gone with the
wind
- Bernard B brown sound recording when
tomorrow comes - Fred surcin for the
special photographic effects the rains
came - Lyle wheeler for art direction
gone with the wind
- eh Hanson for those remarkable sound
effects in the rains came - Herbert
Stothert for the Best Musical scoring
The Wizard of Oz - Harold Arlen an ey
harboured for the ears best song over
the rainbow from The Wizard of Oz the
next introduction is return engagement
by request of the Rhett Butler of the
air Bob Hope - president thank you thank
you ladies and gentlemen I'm very happy
to be here tonight anyway
you don't me I'm just the man who came
to dinner
really I think this is a wonderful thing
of benefit like this for David Selznick
and I want to tell you
I really had a sneaky idea that they
were gonna give me an Oscar tonight
because I saw one of them with a
surprised look here
I think utiful I feel like I'm in Bette
Davis's living room now Bob Hope hands
out Fame in favor to supervising
director ham lust Walt Disney Studios
for the ugly duckling - George bag no
for Paramount short busy little bears
for Warner Brothers Sons of Liberty
producer Gordon Hollingshead accepts a
now come Sinclair Lewis famed American
novelist world-renowned Nobel Prize
winner to present me to Lewis our foster
for the best original motion picture
story mr. Smith goes to Washington and
then mr. Lewis speaks of the Oscar which
betokens the best screen adaptation Gone
with the Wind the screenplay by Sidney
Howard it is a tragedy that many of you
who never knew him personally will
realize that Sidney Howard cannot stand
here tonight to receive that so amply
justified award ladies and gentlemen I
have the pleasure now present a young
young fellow that you all know that
received the juvenile award last year
and I know he's probably one of the most
popular well he is I think the biggest
box-office name in our industry and I
call him the year's 10 best actor mr.
Mickey Rooney ladies
members of the Academy ladies and
gentlemen honored guests it's my
privilege this year to present that Ward
for the outstanding performance by a
juvenile actors during the past year
Miss Judy God
the best direction of 1939 I asked
Mervyn Leroy to present me to Victor
Fleming the man who directed Gone with
the Wind I cannot accept this without
paying tribute to those really
responsible for much of the picture
success the crew behind the camera to
whom I am deeply grateful thank you and
then again a hush over the crowded
Coconut Grove at the mention of a name
now but a warm and glowing memory the
name of Irving Thalberg as dr. Ernest
Martin Hopkins president of Dartmouth
College awards for 1939 the Irving G
Thalberg Memorial to producer David O
Selznick for consistent artistic
achievement during the past year the
hush continues while two Douglas
Fairbanks Jr goes a very special and
honorary award given in deepest sympathy
and gratitude to the family of the late
Douglas Fairbanks I'm sure you all
realize
how difficult it is for me to express
myself adequately you all know I'm sure
how much my father loved motion pictures
and all of you connected with it to have
been given this trophy this reward for
his contributions to this industry would
have made him exceedingly happy thank
you here's a painter a past winner
herself to present the two awards for
supporting performances performances
without which the stars would sometimes
shine not quite so brightly first to
Thomas Mitchell for his brilliant
portrayal in stagecoach
I didn't think I didn't know I was quite
that good I'm really especially happy
that I'm chosen to present this
particular plaque to me it seems I'm
more than just a plaque of gold it opens
the doors of this room moves back the
walls and it Able's us to embrace the
whole of America and America that we
love an America that almost alone in the
world a day recognizes and pays tribute
to those who give their best regardless
of creed race or color it is with the
knowledge that this entire nation will
stand and salute the presentation of
this plaque that I resent the Academy
Award for the best performance of an
actress in supporting role during 1939
the head of Danny
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Science fellow members of the motion
picture industry and honored guests this
is one of the happiest moments of my
life and I want to thank each one of you
who had a part in selecting me for one
of the awards for your kindness it has
made me feel very very humble and I
shall always hold it as a beacon for
anything that I may be able to do in the
future I sincerely hope I shall always
be a credit to my race and to the motion
picture industry my heart is too full to
tell you just hi for you and may I say
thank you Spencer Tracy before
announcing the award to 1939's foremost
actor lists those five best performances
nominated for the honor for the best
performance by an actress
Robert doughnut and goodbye mr. chips
Clark Gable Gone with the Wind
Laurence Olivier in what in height
Mickey Rooney and babes in arms and
James Stewart and mr. Smith goes to
watch
I feel sure that all of the nominees
tonight and all the Academy Award
winners of past years join me in the
great joy I feel in announcing this
winner Robert donut the finest
interpretation of 1939 by an actress
five brilliant performances were
nominated Betty Davis in dark victory
Irene Dunne in love affair
better Garbo in the nuts go
greer garson goodbye mr. chips Vivian
Leigh and Gone with the Wind
need I say it is a privilege and an
honor to announce this winner miss
Vivian Lee in corner
ladies and gentlemen please forgive me
if my words are inadequate in thanking
you'll feel a very great kindness if I
were to mention all those who have shown
me such wonderful generosity through
Gone with the Wind
I should have to entertain you with an
oration as long as Gone with the Wind
itself so if I may I should like to
devote my thanks on this occasion to
that commerce I'd figure energy courage
and very great kindness in whom all
points have gone with the wind meet mr.
David Selznick and so ends 1939's
Academy Awards dinner and so comes 1940
from my vantage point here in Hollywood
I can see my 70,000 workers your workers
mr. and mrs. audience planning scheming
hoping that next year I'm a shimmer
shining Li in their hand which is as it
should be because while they get the
Oscars you mr. and mrs. audience get
better and better picture
you
you